[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the samsung galaxy note 10. you're
probably thinking wait marquez i just
saw this your last video was about the
galaxy note 10 no
that was about the galaxy note 10 plus
the bigger flagship phone with a lot of
the bells and whistles that sort of fits
perfectly in the note brand this
is the galaxy note 10.
it's a bit smaller it's missing a bunch
of what the note 10 plus has
and it's still
950 bucks
and
i still kind of like it
let's talk about it so if i'm being
perfectly real samsung could have maybe
should have called this the note 10e
this phone is a sort of a trimmed down
version in a lot of ways kind of the
same way the s10e was a trimmed down
version of the s10 but for a bit less
money so i think best way to review this
phone is basically to show exactly
what's different about this note 10
versus the note 10 plus that i just
dropped a 15 minute video on so i'll
link that full review right below the
like button if you haven't seen that one
yet this is the note 10. so first of all
it's 150 bucks cheaper like i said which
posted at 9 49 to start and it's kind of
a little brother and i say that because
the most obvious difference is it's
physically smaller now usually i'd
always go for the biggest possible
version of any phone but so many phones
have all gotten so huge these days that
it's actually kind of refreshing having
a smaller flagship phone so the note 10
is smaller than the iphone 10s max
smaller than the oneplus 7 pro i've been
using before i can reach all four
corners fairly easily it's actually
really nice not having to stretch to
reach the top on these giant phones just
to get to notifications
i don't have any one-handed assist
features turned on anymore on this phone
it's kind of nice you know it's been a
while since i've used a phone that's
actually this small which is plenty to
say about a galaxy note it's a 6.3 inch
display uh bezel's still tiny you know
still the boxy overall shape
and another spec difference that a lot
of people focus on is it's now a 1080p
display instead of the 1440p that the
big brother had now this spec is a
perfect example of something that
matters to many people a lot more on
paper than in real life like if you
haven't seen the galaxy note 10 if you
haven't actually used this phone you
might see on the spec sheet that it's
such an expensive phone but it only has
a 1080p display and that sticks out like
a sore thumb but in reality this display
is pretty much great with that
resolution you'd be concerned about
sharpness but it's still pretty sharp at
over 400 ppi so you never really see any
pixels still gets extremely bright or
extremely dim colors still look pretty
good it's just mainly smaller the hole
punch cutout even though it's the same
size appears just a tiny bit bigger
since the phone is smaller but overall
it's still not a huge distraction at all
i think if it was a notch like the
iphone i'd find it a bit more intrusive
on this smaller screen but even you know
full screen videos or gaming and things
like that are still fine here i still do
miss
not having 90 hertz or any sort of high
refresh rate but aside from that this
screen has been pretty excellent
i just think still
because it's 950
you just sort of want it to have
everything you want it to have a 1440p
display at this price so that's one of
the only ways it really feels
disappointing everything else
aesthetically is pretty much identical
to the big brother just shrunken down
which makes things more reachable more
pocketable and more holdable so the
cameras are exactly the same the
speakers are exactly the same the
fingerprint reader is the same and the
buttons are the same but they're even
more reachable so they're a little bit
lower i didn't have a problem reaching
them on the note 10 plus but if you did
these are a little closer the software
is also all still the same but for some
reason and they did this on the galaxy
s10e also on the smaller phone they
don't give you the option to change your
screen resolution
on a phone with a 1440p display they let
you pick if you want to jump down to
1080 or back up on a phone with the
1080p display they hide it maybe it's
because they think it's fine to just
leave it at 1080 max res all the time i
don't know but i would have at least
like to have seen the option here since
this is the galaxy note uh the s pen is
exactly the same too i was actually kind
of wondering if the smaller phone would
get a smaller stylus but nope exact same
stylus on the bigger phone with all the
same features and gestures
and then performance is for all intents
and purposes the same
but with some small spec differences so
the note 10 spec will always be
eight gigs of ram and 256 gigs of that
high speed storage none of that is
expandable here the note 10 plus like we
talked about before can bump up to 12
gigs of ram and 512 gigs of internal
storage and it has the expandable
storage via microsd and i think that for
90 something percent of users that eight
gigs of ram is plenty and the 256 gigs
of storage is enough but if you need
more you should consider the note plus a
couple other small things one uh note 10
has a bit of a smaller battery 3 500
milliamp hours is the official number
kind of small for a flagship actually in
2019 but after using it for a while it
became apparent that it doesn't matter
as much because it has a 1080p display
if you bump up the resolution on the 10
plus you will start to get worse battery
life i kind of left it in the middle got
my four and a half hours of screen on
time this phone with a smaller battery
but a 1080p display got me those same
great numbers for battery about a four
hour screen on time which is pretty good
battery life and then note 10 also lacks
the support for
the super fast 45 watt
ultra fast charger i don't know if
that's a space thing or just a cost
savings thing but it will still come in
the box with a 25 watt charger which is
pretty good if you get the expensive
extra one it'll only work with the 10
plus and then note 10 while i said it
does have the same cameras it doesn't
have the extra depth sensors on the back
as you can see that the 10 plus has
so yeah no ar doodle or anything crazy
with depth sensing like that although it
still does portrait mode and live focus
video just fine so overall
you know there's a good amount of stuff
missing but it's also still very much a
premium phone with a premium build and
the high-end specs and it turns out the
things that were sort of the most
concerning to me which were the display
and the battery life sort of worked
hand-in-hand with each other to be fine
so it's still a great phone in a vacuum
but
we're not in a vacuum this is a world
where other phones or other options
exist this is a world where the galaxy
s10 plus also exists now why do i bring
this up here's the thing here's the
thing samsung is a smart company you
know plenty of smart people working over
there
but
back in just march it seems like they've
made a phone
that's better in a lot of ways than the
note
and for less money galaxy s10 plus came
out just a few months ago
and if you look at how similar they are
they have the same specs you know some
on the s10 plus are actually better so
they both have the snapdragon 85 but you
can go up to 12 gigs of ram it has a
bigger higher resolution display at 6.4
inches and 1440p same ultrasonic
fingerprint sensor better speakers in my
opinion and it has basically the same
triple cameras on the back but sideways
instead of vertical and you get a second
sensor on the front for your depth
sensing that the note doesn't have and
it's much more rounded and tapered of
course but you also get that extra
button so bixby fans it is remappable
and you basically trade the s pen for a
headphone jack and a much bigger 4 100
milliamp hour battery that is that
that's a lot of reasons to get the s10
plus over the note and it's cheaper it
starts at 800 bucks right now in b h and
you can find it for way less than that
and then the note is 950 so
why
does this smaller note 10 exist well
turns out there is a select group of
people that have always really liked the
galaxy note experience or wanted to have
a galaxy note you know s pen and all
but just wanted it to be smaller and the
note's always been a huge phone it's
been basically the phone samsung makes
that's their biggest for the past couple
years this one is smaller it's more
grippable more reachable and that's part
of why i love it so much so for those
who liked the note but wanted it to be
smaller
this phone is for those people so that
puts you in like a really specific
venn diagram overlap of people who like
don't care too much about the specs or
the couple missing features they just
really want the s pen
and a smaller phone
and they have 950 dollars to spend on a
phone
this i guess that's this is that phone
personally i really like this phone a
lot more than i actually thought i would
it's kind of refreshing actually having
a flagship phone be smaller even though
it's still a 6.3 inch display but all
that being said
uh i would still go for
oneplus 7 pro over
this note and over the s10 plus it costs
less than both of these phones and it's
got that higher fresh rate display that
i've been so raving over lately that i
really hope a lot of phones in the
future pick up on you're going to miss
out on things like the better cameras
here and wireless charging but uh
that's where i'd go but hey at least now
we can answer the question in the title
who this phone is for it's that small
group of people
could be you
either way
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace